what's going on guys national master
james canton iii here with chess.com and
today we have the top five
queen sacrifices from the magician
auriga mikhail
tao in this first example we actually
have him playing grand master
alexi sutin so grandmasters alexey suit
is playing uh black here
and white is of course town so bishop d7
was the last move played here in a
sicilian con
it's very very aggressive as you see for
white here we have f5 i mean bishops
looking like they want to do some kind
of work here
the center is being open like the king's
in the center this looks like a disaster
for black hair but after f5
f5 is now here breaking up the center
breaking up all of this and just trying
to open the king's side and rip it apart
e takes f5 g takes f5 and then we have
95
from alexis suit in here so he says all
right cool guys we got to get our pieces
in the center maybe eliminate some of
the
monstrous pieces and attack that he may
have coming here then he plays 96
tao just puts the knight on e6 and
stares at him extremely hard
at this point it's very scary what do
you do you have to get rid of this
knight you actually can't take it this
way
because of the pin but bishop takes c6
this knight
has to go so bishop takes e6 and then he
takes back on e6 himself look at the
file here
i mean look at this file where hey we're
taking on f7 this is open
i mean look how many arrows can i draw
here guys
okay there's a lot going on a lot going
on so
alexi ops in for g6 and just says hey
you have to go you have to go now it's
right to move here guys what would you
actually do here if you were towel in
this position
here it is guys here it is alexis suit
and said you know what you got to move
your queen
and then tao looked at him grabbed his
cree grabbed his queen
and then just took the knight and hit
the clock
sat back real smooth and the game was
over
now he actually really didn't do that
but he felt that queen takes c5 and then
d takes e5 guys first off
look at this beautiful queen sacrifice
the queen is
just sacrificed for a knight not two
rooks
not anything else for a knight and
actually some uh some play here maybe
even some mating attacks i'm also
hitting a rook here so you literally
have to take this queen you only have a
choice why do you even think about it
you just have to take because
he took your knight here now after d
take c5
we have e takes f7 as the rook and the
pawn work very well together and now the
bishops are going to do their job
because now they're ready on an open
board the bishops are ready to
do their thing if king 2fa made on the
move have a nice day
and if he goes this way he jumps right
into a discovery that actually ends this
way
due to engine analysis this is the best
line to take rick takes
rook f8 and then king d7 bishop f5 with
a double check and everything's hanging
you you might as well just push the
queen and the knight off the board you
don't even need them any longer
bishop to f5 king to c6 bishop e4 and
the only move here is knight to d5
this hurts this hurts this is a family
channel let's just get this off the
screen already guys
this is over we have so much material
here and of course everything else is
going to fall at mate soon
to follow here now of course the game
ended right here guys after e takes f7
because he was like you know what i've
had enough
i had enough i know what you're gonna do
people are watching i don't want any
more of this and the game ended
right here and this is example one of
the top five queen sacrifices
of uh mikhail tao now let's move on to
example two
now in this next example we have milko
bobasoft versus mikhail tao in 1958
tao's playing with the black pieces and
the king's indian we have queen e5 as
the last move here
just trying to open up this side of the
board as much as possible and of course
have our pieces aim this way
play for counter play his king is castle
this side whoever gets to the king first
on opposite side castles
is going to win he knows this so after
king b1 and of course i always play king
b1 kind of thing
b5 is now here so now rook b8 may be a
thing capturing opening the file trying
to open the diagonal here
and go from a now this next move by
milko is very interesting and very
strong and you see this is a common
theme
knight to d5 guys he plays knight to d5
here
against tau and tao has a choice here
well of course do we retreat
retreat to d8 and defend the pawn or do
we move the queen or do we take here on
d2 or do we play b4
what do we actually do here guys now
when you're playing town think about
this
when you are playing as tao here i want
you guys to find a move pause the video
if you need to
but when you're playing like this you
have to remember that this is tau so you
have to even consider moves like queen
takes a2 that makes no
sense at all but of course it is tau the
magician from riga half man half
everything else
so we do have to see and calculate these
kind of moves
what would you actually play with black
here
here's the move tal actually picked up
his piece he actually stared at him he
stared at bulbasaur
and played knight takes d5 hit the clock
folded his arms and just sat there
with a very weird stare knight takes d5
is on the board guys he is sacrificing
his queen like it's nothing
let's see exactly what we get for it we
actually get three pieces here or three
three points we took a knight he takes
my queen he gets nine
now okay we get another three points
we'll say like three point two three and
a half the bishop is slightly better
okay
whatever we'll give him three and a half
points there and then now we actually
not taking anything else because he can
move the rook which he does
and after he moves the rook here we only
get a pawn so that equals to what
maybe at at the highest seven and a half
points
maybe seven point two seven points here
not a lot of points here we actually
missed
off by two points because he took a
queen so that's like not equally out but
it actually does
in this kind of position here because of
the counter play that you get in in
addition to the pawns if we look at
white's pieces here they're all locked
in steel they're not doing anything
and ours are pretty active not that
these aren't extremely active this rook
and his knight but they were about to be
and let's see what happens
rook takes c4 he gets rid of it pawn
takes and then knight to uh c1 here
let's fast forward some moves here to
see the play so we can move to the next
example rook to b8 bishop's ac4
and knight to b6 hitting the bishop
being very active here
watch out how tao puts all of his pieces
on the side of the board
where all the action is guys on the side
of the board where all of the action is
he plays c4
make sure we open the file i mean he's
on the defense here every single move
look at this beautiful move here c3 is
coming knight to c4 is a follow-up
man so strong so he plays queen to d3
now we take on b2 now we have holes
around your king here
and then knight to d4 bishop d7 and
watch us swing the pieces in
look at every piece that we own is in
this attack this is how you
attack like a magician bishop to b3
knight e4 we're going to do knight to c3
check
so he gets rid of it bishop takes knight
to b3 hey just keep the threats rolling
rook to c3
queen takes bishop takes b3 takes and
here we go
nice move here we're actually
threatening this but we're also
threatening
other things as well like discoveries so
if king takes we actually have a check
here there may be better checks but
this is just the easiest check right out
of the bat here we literally just win
the queen back and we're up
decisive material here but uh with that
being said the last move was queen to a3
not even sure what he's doing here i
think he's just trying to stop this
but the end of the day he's still losing
after rook check
then he's instead of taking with the
pawn guys he actually takes with the
rook
and then king 282 and that's made on the
move guys mate on the move
wow what a beautiful checkmate you don't
see that very often right
and this was example number two of the
top five queen sacrifices from the
magician of riga
mikhail tao now let's move on to example
number three
now this next example is hans hyokim
heck versus mikhail tao back in 1962
this is a very
famous queen sacrifice guys now if you
have seen this before
then this is a joy for you this is a
reminder if you haven't seen this before
then i highly recommend you pause the
video
and see what you can do here it's
actually white to move right now guys as
we reach a queen's indian
uh position a caspar variation queen's
indian is what happened in this opening
and now we get to a very very sharp
position
at a crossroad roads where my queen on
a4
is attacked my knight is attacked on c4
there are some problems here
so we need to address it but also this
is hanging on f6
so what do you actually do here guys
like to move
here's what tau did tao was feeling very
great that day
and he looked up he looked down he
looked around the room
and then he thought about life and he
said you know what
he didn't even think about it he just
took the knight he takes f6
he's gonna take it we got enough play i
see everything
e takes f6 here it is guys a spectacular
queen sacrifice watch what's about to
happen next b takes a4 okay
so now we have a queen here this is what
he does i mean he sacrifices queens in
his sleep
b takes a4 and f takes g7 now we're
hitting the rook here we're threatening
to actually take on g6 too as well
maybe i mean rookie one's coming like we
got some serious compensation here and
also look at the king
king is not really looking too good on
spaces he has king d7 these pieces are
virtually out of the game
whoa like and then you stop and look and
understand the compensation
this could be very bad for black rook to
g8 on the board here then a spectacular
follow-up move here guys
many players would play what move here
i'm sure you're thinking and if you
aren't thinking you should probably
think here and stop
pause the video what would you actually
play as white but here rookie one right
rookie one seems like a natural move
especially if you're just playing
quickly ricky won
you just play rookie one tower was like
a bishop f5
and be live bishop f5 what a move
beautiful guys this seals the deal on
the spot i don't have to win the queen
with the rook
i can win a queen with my bishop so if
he takes this this bishop here
queen takes f5 we have knight to d6 jack
and we come back and we're doing great
actually we have so much so much that we
can do here so much potential
maybe even rookie seven sometimes in
certain lines but uh bishop to f5
beautiful move here
now at the bishop at five we have knight
takes h4 he says i'm just going to get
rid of it it's time to get rid of this
piece
so after bishop takes e6 then uh bishop
to a6
and knight to d6 from tao king e7 bishop
to c4 and now we're not losing any
material
as we're able to take care of everything
everything's defended you take my knight
i take your bishop
you take my bishop i take back these
pawns look crazy here it's just not
looking the best actually i mean
and white's white's going to definitely
do some damage here just because of the
fact that king's in the center this
knight is kind of out
of play it's not really good rick takes
g7 and there's g3 here
g3 from the night now of course there's
many many moves here guys um and tal
went on to win this game guys
but it's the example part here they got
very wild that i wanted to show you guys
i was so excited to show you guys this
one if you've never seen it before
instead of just retreating guys this
will get your mind
in in the realm of the magician himself
you don't always have to move a piece if
it's threatened now of course you will
lose many games if you don't do that but
at the same
time you can win mini games if you think
outside the box
or inside the box or inside tiles
box or a head or whatever b takes a four
and an f takes g
f g seven and rig the g8 and bishop f5
beautiful display here guys after b5
there's pawn takes f6 he didn't even
think about it of course he thought
about it but here
this was a very a very very nice way to
do this is taking here taking the knight
first
making complications and tal is the king
of making
complications for his opponent this is
why he's my favorite player i love to
create complications and tactics guys
and this was awesome to actually see it
be takes a 4 ft g7
rook g8 bishop f5 guys knight takes h4
and we got into this position where he
went on to win the game
and this guy's was example number three
now let's move on to example number four
the next example we have isaac berbreger
versus mikhail tao with the black pieces
there was a benoni defense from before
the opening here we got to a very wild
position
what else would we get with plane tail
so we have a wild position here as we
see this pawns this knight's hanging
right here the queen looks like he's
locked out
this bishop's over here this it's just
wild this is what you expect to see when
you're walking and you look at tao's
board and you're like oh yeah
typical towel position rook to g2 what
happens for black hair he actually takes
on f3
queen takes f3 doesn't care about
anything here maybe you can do stuff
like bishop to h3 and there's all kind
of things that can happen here he just
takes on f3 and says forget it and then
you know what instead of even taking a
knight he didn't want any trouble there
he just says oh knight d2 tao i'm not
gonna i'm not playing that game with you
i'm just not
so he plays queen to e3 here now still
threatening stuff like f3 this check
could be deadly as well there's many
things that can happen
and after queen to e3 there's knight to
f1 now he goes back
and says i'll take a draw queen f3
knight d2 i'll take a draw yeah
i'm not going through all those
complications with you town yeah i'll
take a draw here
now with black to move guys as he's
thinking and contemplating should he
take this draw
what actually would you do in this
position
instead of taking the draw here instead
of taking the draw
tao was like you know what day is it
what time is it
it could be like you know what yep it's
that time and then he sacrificed his
queen bishop takes g4 didn't even think
about it
it's there on the board bishop takes g4
and then knight takes f3
bishop takes and now this is crazy this
actually doesn't even look like there's
enough compensation
but in fact there is after bishop takes
f4 there's h4 on the board now of course
the the things that were happening is
this could be a thing like you almost
don't have many defenses to these kind
of things
also bishop moves bishop takes c4 so
maybe doing this
doubling playing rookie five doubling
the rooks here and playing like rook to
g5
especially if bishop e2 moves i mean
look at the tie down i mean
he's so miraculous at tying down pieces
to be able to do only one thing and one
thing only so after bishop takes f3
there's h4 on the board and then rook to
f8
and then we'll make a few more moves
here to show you guys what happened
bishop to e2
knight g3 king h2 and then he takes on
g2 and honestly guys he went on to win
this game let's check the next
the next few moves look at that queen's
back hey thanks for the queen appreciate
it bro
takes takes check check and bishop f4
and actually he went on to win this game
guys
but back to the spectacular moment here
instead of taking that draw
you can always look for that advance now
of course i've been i'm not sure if i'm
talking to anyone here
watching the video but you know
sometimes you push on and you lose a
drawn game
but here this is tau this is how it's
his time
his kind of sacrifice he sacrificed the
queen saw that he had compensation for
it
how much compensation it's also the
shock factor over the board that he took
into account to
of not being of surprising his opponent
here and it actually worked out in his
favor here so
this was example number four of the top
five queen sacrifices
by tau now guys let's look at the final
example
now in this last example guys we have
roman taran
albero versus mike altao guys this last
game was actually a
reverse sicilian here and which was in
english so it actually started with one
c4 now in this position guys of course
it gets scary it's kind of
weird it looks like white's doing fine
here but also black has the bishops here
but it could be deadly because of the
center
you just don't know it's just a wild
position as we always see with the towel
here
now after queen to d2 rook 2e8 is
actually placed here
putting some pressure on this knight but
also the bishop so you know roman
realizes what's going on and plays
knight g5 because we're going to check
right here
and would let you let you do whatever
you want like we're going to check you
right here it's going to be bad when we
follow it with knight f7
unless maybe it might not be he actually
said rook takes e3
whoa come and get me brooke takes c3
come and get me
and then he plays bishop to d5 check now
guys what do you actually do here
what do you actually do pause the video
can you find the next two moves here
after king h8 and knight f7
what do you do what do you do guys kha
knight f7 so are we going back to g8
what would you do are we trying it again
but here's what happens tell actually
says i'm not doing
any of that queen takes f7 i'll take
that one
too my good friend i'll take that one
too from you he didn't care about it
yeah i moved my king to the corner
knight of seven
at this point we now have a bishop and
we have a knight
for the queen that we're sacrificing
after the queen's gone bishop
rick to d3 first and now bishop to d4
check
there it is hit the man with the move
here very nice look at the play here
it's going to be very scary this was the
key move it seals the deal
this rook to d3 followed by bishop to d4
check king is here we don't want to go
to the corner because there's mating
threats
that could happen so we need to have an
escape square so after king g2 95. now
we're getting everything into the play
here
bishop to g4 is looking nice rook here
followed by some checks
wow look at how all the pieces work
together in great harmony
very harmonious way to play after
sacrificing a queen here
now after work to d1 rook to e3
queen f1 there's a check and then
there's rook to f3 and this game is
already over guys this game is already
over here
this bishop's hanging so he's gonna try
a few moves here queen e2
just to defend and then after bishop f5
he just resigns
bishop at five the game's completely
over here i mean after king to
h4 i think the best move here is
actually bishop e3
followed by g5 is that what the engine
says i think
i think that was the uh the lines here
um from from looking at that you also
have king g7 followed by h6 and g5
there's some a few moves you can play
here but i think bishop e3 is actually
the best
and it is it is because this bishop is
hanging so bishop b3 and bishop to g5 or
h6 g5
kind of stuff and putting a bishop on g5
will be mate bishop e3
h6 bishop g5 looks very nice here you
have many ways to win and of course tal
went on to win this game guys
it was an excellent way of of
sacrificing a queen and
following up with powerful moves let's
look at that again back here guys
back here reverse sicilian everything's
going fine
white's defending like he's good he's
doing great oh nike five
i got him guys you know i got him and
then busy
rook takes e3 he's like okay yeah i mean
i'll give you that i'll give you that
and then check and then he takes it and
you know probably his eyes got
huge here he took it then you have to
realize i'm playing tao
so then he just relaxes and just like
well i'm just going to have to go
through the motions at this point
bishop takes rook d3 check and then 95
oh my goodness and the game is
completely over after a few more moves
guys this was the top
five queen sacrifices from mikhail
tao the magician from riga and my
favorite player guys
and i'm national master james canty the
third with chess.com i hope you enjoyed
the video
make sure you like and subscribe here at
the channel guys and i'll see you
on the next video